MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 102
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm
here with my colleague Melanie
Warrick.
Hello, Melanie, how
are you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm doing good.
How's the jet lag treating you?
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
it's not too bad.
Just got back from
Australia last week.
Melatonin is wonderful.
It helps remarkably.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, I definitely
can find there's some benefit
to that, as well as sunlight,
getting lots of sunlight
once you get back.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool.
So this week we have a wonderful
interview with Brian Granatir.
He's come to talk to us
all about Smart Parking IoT
Core, serverless, all sorts
of amazing, cool stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
I'm excited actually
to hear this interview
because I think
this is a problem that it seems
so obvious that technology
can help us with.
So it's great that
we have him on.
But something to
note for everybody
is if you didn't catch
this from last week,
Francesc is still doing
the main interviews.
Those have been prerecorded
for the interviews that
are going on through
the rest of the year,
while I'll be helping
with the intros
and outros up until
the end of the year,
and then we'll be taking on
the main content from there.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome so excited.
So glad to have you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, so
don't be surprised or shocked
if Francesc is still there.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
The ghost of Francesc.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's good.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Awesome.
And then after the
main content, we
have our Question of the Week.
We'll be talking
about how do you
configure a Postgres Cloud SQL
instance for high availability.
But before we get into
all that, why don't we
talk about our Cool
Things of the Week.
Melanie, did you
want to go first?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure,
I'll start with a couple.
I'm going to mention that
they've got this article that's
out there on the "Google
Cloud Platform" blog,
and it talks about how
machine learning is
used for speech recognition.
It's kind of a nice
overview and touches
on just looking at wavelengths,
applying Fourier transform,
also using hidden Markov models.
Not Mark as in Mark who's
speaking, but Markov.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] And
it has a pretty diagram
that I can click things on.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
there is a nice diagram.
And the link will be provided
on the "GCP Podcast" blog.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Cool.
We should probably
make note of the fact
that GCP now has a whole
brand new region, which
is pretty amazing,
in the Mumbai region,
so another great spot
in the APEC region.
They have availability for
App Engine, Compute Engine,
Container Engine,
Dataproc, Datalab,
a whole bunch of
other stuff as well.
But the really cool thing,
I think, for that area
is that you're able now to
pay in local currency as well.
So now if you want to pay for
Google Cloud Platform products,
you can do so in rupees.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
also, it definitely
is a value of from a
latency standpoint.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And there's definitely
so much cool tech
going on in that region.
So it should be really,
really, really exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Finally, we have high
availability and replication
for Cloud SQL for Postgres.
That was definitely a missing
feature for a little while,
and a lot of people gave
us feedback on that.
So if you need
failover or you want
to be able to set up read
replicas for your Postgres
instances, that is
now available for you
to take advantage of on
Google Cloud Platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: That'll be fun.
All right, well, I
think it's time for us
to get into that interview.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
let's go talk to Brian.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very excited today
to welcome Brian Granatir,
software developer
and technical lead
at Smart Parking
and also owner of six
dogs, living in New Zealand
but from Oregon.
Hello, how are you doing?
[LAUGHS]
BRIAN GRANATIR: I'm
doing wonderful.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for joining us.
So before we get started
talking about Smart Parking
and how it is to be a developer
down there, not in Australia
this time, but in New Zealand.
Why don't you tell us little
bit about yourself, what you do,
who you are.
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah, so,
like you said in the intro,
I'm Brian.
I've been a software developer
for, ooh, a long time,
probably since the beginning
of this whole cloud thing.
So my original beginnings
were with Hewlett Packard,
did some work there, and
then transitioned over here
to New Zealand.
And I've worked with a
couple of companies here.
And like you said, proud owner
of a large massive pack of dogs
and proud to be a kiwi.
So that's kind of the
short line about me.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well, why
don't you tell us
a little about Smart
Parking, or I should
say (AMERICAN ACCENT) parking.
Oh, god.
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS]
"Smaht Pahking."
MARK MANDEL: "Smaht
Pahking," I'll make sure
the accents coming out.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about Smart Parking
and what does it do,
what's it all about.
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah, so Smart
Parking is a company that
develops parking technologies.
So for most of our
clients, that's
in-ground sensors, or what
we call camera gateways.
And we've been developing that
for, oof, years and years now.
And we have installations in
New Zealand, Australia, the UK,
Dubai, Singapore, and
a few other places.
I can never keep
track of all of them.
And so we've been
working on these
for years and the services and
the mobile apps and everything
to support that.
And then at the
start of this year,
we've begun our
new endeavor, which
was to create a Smart
Cities Platform.
And the goal of that is to take
all of these different devices
and messages that you
might get from a city,
be it traffic, parking,
weather, energy grids, lighting,
and kind of bring them
all together, kind
of connecting IoT of things
together to one platform
and then deriving
meaning off of that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I'd love to dig more into what
actually this Smart Parking
stuff is.
You said you're doing analytics?
Is it just like who
parks where, what, why?
Or is it like real-time
stuff, that when
people come to a
car park, they can
be directed to free parking?
Like this actually
sounds really cool,
so I'm super curious
about what it does.
BRIAN GRANATIR:
Yeah, definitely.
Yes, so what we do is we
offer network services.
So the one that's very
common is sometimes
you'll go to a
parking structure,
and they'll tell you
there's 12 bays available
on the second floor, but
there's 150 bays available
on the third floor.
And our sensors are
detecting those vehicles
arriving and going.
They also help with
enforcement, so very common
in downtown areas or near
government buildings.
They'll put in our sensors and
say, well, you got 30 minutes.
And then after you
go on for 30 minutes,
we can let an enforcement
officer know to go over
and ticket the person.
So sometimes when you
get those tickets,
you can curse our names.
But then also we offer a
variety of other services.
Like I mentioned, we
do have a mobile app
that people can use
and say, hey, while I'm
driving downtown, I want to find
parking near to the stadium.
Can you help me out?
And we'll tell you what
the parking availability is
in various areas and help to
navigate the driver to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I'm curious.
All of this, what kind of
technology are you using?
Are you using the cloud?
It sounds like
internet of things.
Tell us a little bit about that.
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yes.
So the old platform, so
what we professionally
refer to as a version 2,
was all 100% home-built.
So it's using
custom-built devices
that are installed on the
ground and custom gateways that
broadcast the stuff back
to our network services
and goes to our servers.
We did do a transition of
those servers out to AWS.
And that was kind of
the structure that
worked for us for a long time,
But now with the
new platform, we've
actually built the whole thing
out on Google Cloud Platform,
which gave us a whole
new set of opportunities.
And this is when we started to
embrace the internet of things,
right?
Not just our device,
but any device
that wants to be able to
kind of join our party
is able to send us the
messages, and we're
able to aggregate,
analyze, and act upon all
those different devices.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So how do you do that?
[LAUGHS]
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS] Well,
that's the real magic of it.
So the real trick to it
is first and foremost, you
got to get the data in, right?
So you have to get
it all coming to us.
And that's where the
IoT thing comes in.
And there's a lot
of different devices
out there, everything
from our sensors,
which are parking
sensors in the grounds,
to there's even trash
cans that will tell you
when they're too full.
There's lighting sensors,
the IoT, the actual devices.
So we need to get them coming
into us, first and foremost.
And that's what we
use IoT Core for.
So Google, I think, just made--
they did.
They made their announcement to
make the public for the beta.
We've been using it now
for a couple of months.
And that was what really
helped us get the data in.
Then once you get
the data in, that's
where you start having
to say, all right,
how am I going to
normalize this?
How am I going to take data
from trash cans and data
from parking and the
data from traffic
to be able to make a picture?
So one of the things
that we like to do
is we like to use examples of
what a city might do for this.
So we might be able to
detect, all right, well,
suddenly, at 9:00 PM we see
a bunch of people departing.
All the parking's emptying
out in the downtown area.
Maybe a concert's emptied.
In our platform, the idea
that we can detect that
and say, hey, well, we see
a whole bunch of people
are leaving the downtown area.
Let's change our traffic
lights to help outbound traffic
leaving downtown.
So that's the kind of idea
of a smart city, right?
Taking data from one thing,
putting it somewhere else,
taking the fact
that we've detected
there's a giant rainstorm over
on I-5, and what I want to do
is reduce the
speeds for everyone
there on the digital signs.
So you have to say, all
right, we've got the data.
We have the goal.
Now how do we get that
all to work together?
And that's been the kind of
magic we've been working on.
We've been using an event-driven
architecture to do that.
So we look at
everything as events.
And we also use what's called
spatiotemporal tagging,
so it's space and time.
Yeah, yeah, there's
some amazing articles.
You drop that word
in conversation,
people are like, ooh.
We use spatiotemporal tagging.
And then we use
temporal reasoning.
Those are all great things.
There's some amazing
white papers.
But it basically
comes into the idea
that everything comes into
us, and it knows the place,
and it knows the time.
And then what we do is we use
the event-driven architecture
to make these aggregates and
start clumping them together.
We make these basically
events of events.
So without getting
too technical,
in temporal reasoning.
MARK MANDEL: Get technical
as technical as you like.
[LAUGHS]
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I highly
recommend-- there's
some great papers on
temporal reasoning out there.
It's actually becoming
a really big thing.
Because with AI and
machine learning,
which is another thing
that we like to leverage,
you start looking at things
in the relationship of what
happened when.
And what you do is you put
them in these things called
intervals.
And intervals are made
up of smaller events.
So for example, a lecture
could be an interval.
And during that
lecture, I could say,
introduction,
Brian makes a joke,
Q&A, and then wrap-up, right?
And that's an interval.
It's a sequence of events.
And then what you
can do is you can
use those intervals
in relationship
to bigger and smaller intervals.
So you can say, hey,
well, an interval could
be work day, which is made up of
four lectures and a lunch time,
right?
And then what you
do is you start
using logic that
says, all right, well,
if I've seen A happen before
B, but c hasn't happened yet,
then I trigger some
sort of behavior.
So it's easy to
say those examples.
Getting it actually
implemented in a way
that people can
easily-- normal humans
can-- interact with it
is kind of the trick.
And we've used a couple
of methodologies to that.
So that's kind of the overview.
Get the data in
through IoT Core.
Do some big, old processing
with event architecture.
Do some temporal reasoning
on spatiotemporal tags.
And there you go,
smart city, that easy.
MARK MANDEL: So you're saying
get the data in from IoT Core.
Where does that go?
Does that go to like GCP?
Does it go to a particular
GCP product or products?
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yes.
Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So how
does that part work?
BRIAN GRANATIR:
Yeah, and this is
why I was happy to do this
podcast because a lot of this
is the magic of actual
GCP coming in, right?
So one of the things
that we did was
when we were sitting
there and saying,
all right, we know
what we want to do it.
We want to get this
data in from cities.
One of the biggest concerns
was just the sheer volume
of the data, right?
Just parking alone,
you have hundreds
of events per
single lot per hour,
right, cars coming
and going, staying.
And our sensors don't send you
messages that are just like,
oh, the vehicles left.
The vehicles come.
No, they're actually reporting
as often as they get changes
in the sensor, right?
So an IR or a magnetic
change could be caused
by a whole bunch of things.
It's sending the message to us.
So just parking alone, let alone
putting in traffic, weather,
or any other data is just
a huge volume of data.
And so this is
one of the reasons
that we turned to Google.
Google's products
and services are
built to work with
Google's problems, right?
You're talking Google scale.
Cities are pretty big, not
quite Google scale, right?
So if we can use
systems that will
handle the entire
internet, they'll
probably work on cities.
There's still pretty big,
but not quite as big.
So that was the first thing.
We said, all right,
we want to use Google.
But fortunately, Google's
different services
have best practices
baked in, right?
They really do.
They have this
kind of philosophy.
Not only did they design
it to meet their needs,
they also designed it to meet
the kind of sciencey side
of things, right?
That there's the best
practices baked in.
So we said, all right,
let's use Google.
That's going to meet our scale.
I'd never done anything with GCP
before starting this project.
I was an AWS person, did
AWS for a decade, loved it.
And then we said,
well, we're going to go
try Google for this thing.
And then you just start putting
the boxes together, right?
Like I said, it sounds
really, really complicated.
But building it's actually
really, really fast.
So you bring in
messages from IoT Core.
And then they go into a Pub/Sub.
So people are maybe familiar
with the queues that Pub/Sub
subs are-- love them--
the very backbone of what we do.
And in many ways,
the very backbone
of a real event-driven
architecture
is being able to have
these kinds of queues
that people subscribe to.
And they can get
notified of events.
So messages come in.
Cars left.
Traffic's going up.
We've detected
increased precipitation.
Those messages come in.
They get routed into
queues in Pub/Sub.
And then the systems
that subscribe
to it are Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions are Google's
serverless architecture.
Oh, I love the Cloud Functions.
They're amazing.
Like, if you haven't written
anything in Cloud Functions,
I recommend anyone who
does web services do it.
It's similar to AWS's Lambda.
But, again, it's built
in to kind of deliver
this through-put,
this massive scale.
So messages come in.
They get routed out through
the queues through Pub/Sub.
And then we have Cloud
Functions pick them up.
And then they start doing
their processing, right?
They do one thing, and they
do one thing really well.
So this is the dream, right?
You may have heard we
want microservices, right?
Everyone's like that's the goal.
We want microservices.
And I've tried building
micro services.
Now this is my third attempt.
And it is the first
time I've actually
been able to achieve
true microservices.
And that's because
a couple of things.
One, you run these
Cloud Functions
through little serverless
functions, right?
They do one thing.
They do that thing really well.
They come online
when they're needed.
And then they shut down.
And so that's the step, right?
And so our system, which was all
that complicated stuff I said,
right?
All the fancy words I
used is nothing more
than a set of dots
connected together that are
these little Cloud Functions.
And every single one of them,
with the exception of one,
which is the one
function I hate,
is under 100 lines of code.
In fact, almost all of them are
under 30 lines of code, right?
They literally bring the
thing in, do one thing,
and then pass it on, right?
And so that's the
trick, right, taking
a very complicated thing,
and then breaking it down.
So everything that
comes in our system,
for the adventure in
architecture junkies,
commands coming in, we
convert them to events.
And then we just have things
react to those events,
right, creating new commands,
creating new events,
creating new commands,
creating new events.
And the secret sauce
comes into being
able to find a way
to say, I'm going
to use that geospatial, that
spatiotemporal data so the time
and the location to be able
to start grouping together
these events and then try to
grab meaning from the larger
view of what a city's
going on, what's
the actual living, happening
events within the city.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So that give us is a
actually pretty specific idea
even of how you do what you do.
But there is a
piece of all of this
that I'm actually
very interested in.
You were saying, like, once we
have the data, then we do this.
How do you get that data?
How does the data goes from
the sensors to that Pub/Sub?
Could you tell us a little
bit more about that?
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah.
And that's where
IoT Core comes in.
So this is the thing
that was the kind
of the secret, the thing that
kind of unlocked it for us.
So previously what
we did is we said,
well, we're going
to get a device.
And then it's going to
send us information.
It's going to go into
one of our gateways,
and we're going to handle it.
But now with IoT Core, able to
say, well, what we want to do
is we want to let any
device send us a message in.
So IoT core is basically
a management platform
for devices.
Google has one.
AWS has one.
I think it's called AWS IoT
Platform, for reference.
And it fills in this
new gap, where you say,
well, I've got a device, and I
need it to get me this message.
Now, that used to
be really painful.
But IoT Core gives
you the security,
which is if I can
say, hey, something's
giving me the security,
and it's Google security,
so you know it's really good.
So they give you the security.
They also let you do the device
management, where you say, hey,
I'm going to install
on your device.
Here are the credentials.
It makes the communication.
It sets up all the routing.
And then you can then
start sending messages in,
and you also have a feedback
loop so you can send messages
back out.
So let's say I need to
push a firmware update
or I need to do
something like that,
I handle that two-way
communication.
So I don't know how
familiar you are with IoT,
but IoT basically consists
of sensors, devices,
connected to gateways.
They may be co-located
with the sensor.
But that's the thing that's
responsible for handling
the communication.
At this point, it just
talks to IoT core.
There's actually
a lot of companies
that are making gateways.
Intel's been one of
them and a couple others
that you guys have--
I'm pretty sure you've
got a good partner
list on the website that make
the gateways that fill in that.
So you can say, well, I've
got a device over here,
but I didn't really think
about how I was going
to handle the communication.
They do gateways.
Our system, we offer a smart
spot for our smart cloud, which
is a generic gateway
that allows you to say,
hey, I'm going to accept
broadcasts from any device,
package them up,
and then send them
into the smart
cloud, or IoT Core,
management's front end
or the back end that
goes off IoT Core.
And then so you basically,
you kind of get this thing.
You get devices.
They're sending you this data.
And I'm sure like a lot
of people, when you first
heard about IoT Core--
well, maybe, it's just me.
I'm kind of skeptical about
a lot of stuff, right?
When people told me that
cloud was the next big thing,
I'm like, mm, it's
just servers, guys.
It's just-- but then
now I love the cloud.
I couldn't live without it.
Then when they said,
oh, here comes IoT,
and I'm like, well, IoT,
what, smart fridges are
going to connect with
my smart shopping cart.
It's going to connect
everything together,
and everything's going
to work magically.
Well, it's one of the
things where you're like,
it's a pipe dream.
Give it another 20 years, right?
But the introduction
of these kind
of platforms, these management
services, this IoT Core
has basically
removed that hurdle.
Now you can say, hey,
I've got it installed.
It's connected to these devices.
They're getting the security
certificates installed
through the process
of just getting
them the installation process.
And then the data just
starts flowing in.
And IoT Core allows you to
direct that into a Pub/Sub,
right?
It's connected directly
into the service.
So IoT Core allows you do that.
So to give a kind of
assessment of how it went,
we started with our
own homegrown system.
We got IoT Core into
the private beta.
It took one of our
engineers, Ken,
I think it took them three days
to transfer everything over
from the old system to IoT Core.
So we went from using
our stuff to using
IoT Core, which has
Google security,
hooks directly into the
Pub/Subs, everything,
three days, one engineer.
So that was one of the things
that just kind of sold me
on the whole thing.
And guess what?
We've had the thing
up and running.
I haven't touched since.
I haven't done a thing to it.
We just install more devices.
We install more gateways.
That's it.
And we haven't had any problems.
We haven't had
anything fall over.
We haven't had any issues.
It's just worked.
It's just sending me a ton
of data, and it's that easy.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
kind of curious now,
as well, because I know nothing
about the IoT side of things.
I'm guessing you have some
kind of manufacturing process
for building these devices or
constructing them in some way.
Is there some special
hooks into IoT?
Like, how do you get the IoT
Core thing on the device?
You must have some
kind of factory.
Like, how does that work?
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah.
Yeah.
So we do have custom-built
sensors for ours--
so the ones that we do install.
But that actually
isn't required.
You don't have to actually
go this whole custom route.
So what you can do is you
basically have two parts.
So part one is the thing
that's doing the sensing.
So it could be something that
detects the amount of particles
of bacteria in your fridge
to tell you how much you're
butter's rotten.
I don't know.
Or it could be a sensor that
tells you how many cars are
driving over a road.
Or it could be something
that tells you parking.
You build the sensor.
You build the device.
And then all you
need to do is have
something that takes
that information,
packages it up, and
then sends it through.
So those are the gateways.
So you can be a kind of
separation of the two.
You don't have to
build both of them.
They don't need to be custom.
The sensors usually are.
But the gateways definitely
don't need to be.
But you can make it
be anything you want.
So one of my
developers right now,
we're prototyping
some other stuff.
And he just made it so that
his webcam is an IoT thing.
And any time a blue object
passes in front of it,
it detects that a blue object
has passed in front of it.
We're using Google's Vision API
to detect the analysis, right?
So somebody blue
passes in front of it.
One of our developers happens
to like to wear a blue jacket.
So he walks in front of it.
Whenever that camera
detects it, it packages up,
sends it through a
gateway, which it's just
self-contained in the code.
And it literally hits IoT Core.
So his webcam, with a little
bit of code behind it,
is literally an IoT
Core device, right,
designed to detect the
presence of blue objects.
So you could do anything you
want for these IoT things.
And you don't want to
be restrictive, right?
If you say, oh, you've got
to have a special gateway,
or you've got to have a special
handshake or anything, that's
where you start basically
making it a walled garden.
But you don't want that.
So like our smart spots
are designed to facilitate.
What you usually
see in cities is you
see radio frequencies, right?
So you don't get to run wires.
And very often the Wi-Fi
stuff is not going to give you
the kind of--
well, it just hasn't been
deployed across cities.
But like our in-ground sensors?
Radio frequencies.
These smart trash cans?
So our smart spot's
designed to sit there
and say, well, I'm going
to take in any message
coming over radio frequencies.
I'm going to package it up.
I'm going to wrap
it with information.
And then I'm going to send
it to the smart cloud.
And then we take it, and then
when it gets to back end,
we're able to say, oh,
that's from a trash can.
Let's decode it.
And then let's turn
it into a command that
goes into an event, and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
So getting in all this data,
where are you storing it?
Obviously, you're doing a lot
of analytics and processing
and sorts of other fun
stuff over the top.
Like where does this
actually end up?
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah, and
that's the other thing.
So I think one of the things
you have to also look at
is just the scale, like I
said, right, lots of data.
So for us, what we
wanted to do was say,
well, we want to be able to
make the databases two things.
One, we need our databases
to be very simple,
because I don't want to have
to generate and maintain
shifting schema.
So went with NoSQL.
And two, we want to be
true microservices, which
means that every single one
of our little functions,
every single service has
its own database, right?
So if you're telling me,
hey, we have currently,
I think, in our
connected dots, right,
our Pub/Subs to Cloud Functions
to Pub/Subs to Cloud Functions,
I think there's currently
89 dots, 89 functions that
have 89 databases.
And how do we do that?
Well, we use Google's Datastore.
So Datastore is they're
not an SQL thing.
And actually in Cloud functions.
I can take any object, just,
literally, a chunk of JSON
object.
And I can just say,
save it to Datastore,
and it's that simple.
It's literally one line of code.
And I'm just taking data,
and I'm putting it in.
And then when I need to get
it later, I pull it out.
And so you get this synergy,
this connectivity between all
of these different
services, Pub/Subs
feeding the Cloud Functions,
Cloud Functions leading
into Datastore.
And the best thing
about it is it's
a incredibly scalable and
super cheap, like crazy cheap.
And that's the
thing that makes it
so that you can be fearless
with your databases.
That's the thing that I
think I really, really like.
When you're sitting
there-- and I've
used different
databases for everything
you can imagine across
every cloud service.
But the thing that
you want to be
is you want to be
really fearless.
You want to be, hey,
I've got to do service.
I just spun it up.
It does nothing but
take in the data that's
coming in from a
sensor, and it checks
if the IR is within
a known range.
Otherwise it sends an alert.
And I just want to maintain
everything it's ever
read in a database, right?
In the old days,
you'd be like, ooh,
how many messages
is that going to be?
Mm, well, I probably average
around 1,000 a minute, right?
And you're like, ooh,
that's going to add up.
Maybe we'll archive it.
Maybe we're going
to do something.
But what you can do is
you can say, no, actually,
just put it in Datastore, right?
It's super easy.
It's super cost-effective.
It scales great, and it's
just there on demand.
So that the things that we love.
It's just the one
extra thing that I
don't have to think about.
I don't have to think about
maintaining databases.
I don't think about, oh, how
are our costs going to go?
And I mentioned the cost, right?
It's like I've looked
at the numbers for it
this morning about some of
what our cost things and stuff.
Yeah, so for example,
our dev site--
so remember we use Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub's the
queuing service.
We have a third of a terabyte
of data on the dev-- on the dev,
not the staging,
not the production,
on our dev one, where
we're just kind of running
test data and stuff there.
So we're running
through about a third
of a terabyte of data going
through Pub/Sub there.
And I think it's like, yeah,
$16 to push all that data.
So you're looking at
that scale, right?
You're saying, just
I'm getting data.
I'm branching it like crazy.
I mean, everywhere,
every event is
going into a different Pub/Sub
so that you can subscribe
to these different events.
It cost us $16 for
a month of the data
we were pushing through there.
For the Pub/Subs, so
those little dots,
the little micro services
that do one thing
and do them really
well, in September
we had 96 million invocations.
That was 3,300 processing hours.
So we were using 3,300 of
our serverless server time.
All that together?
$130.
So this is literally
the data that we're
getting from just
deluges of data coming
in from these sensors telling us
the readings every few seconds,
every minute, depending
on the device.
It costs is $130 to manage,
to process that data.
And then you say, all right,
where are we going to put it?
We're going to put it
in good, old Datastore.
We think we had
around 200 million
reads going through the system.
So we're storing all that data.
We're reading it
200 million times.
We're doing all this stuff.
And it costs us $100.
So we're looking at a
sophisticated platform that
is built to match the
modern architecture,
this event-driven architecture.
And you're able to do
it cost-effectively.
Like the first
time I ever pitched
event-driven architecture, and
it comes with aggregates, comes
with all these other
things, I was sitting
there talking with colleagues.
And we're going through
it, and we're like, man,
to do this right,
you're going to have
to have a ton of databases.
You're going to have to
have tons of systems.
have tons of these things.
You're like, the cost is
just going to be too much.
It's just like, it's
a great architecture.
It makes a lot of sense.
But it doesn't make a
lot of sense financially.
And that was one of the
really painful moments
being a professional, right?
You're like, I got it.
I got the secret.
I can do this thing using
event-driven architecture.
But then when you look
at it, you're like,
it's too expensive.
Just go do it the old way.
But with GCP and Pub/Sub and
Cloud Functions and Datastore,
you're actually free
to make these kinds
of new-era architectures, these
event-driven architectures, all
these other ones
that are out there.
Really say, hey,
if the domain, it's
the main that's going to decide
what I'm to do, not the costs.
And that's really
liberating, right?
So I am literally taking
just deluges of data,
and I'm just storing it.
And I'm not just
storing it once.
I may store it
multiple times, right?
I might say, well, I
got it in, and here's
information about the device.
It branched to another command,
another Cloud Function.
And it's seeing the same thing,
and they're both saving it,
right?
And if you told me
literally a year ago,
hey, Brian, you're going
to duplicate, triple,
replicate all this
data, and you're just
going to put it
all over the place
and you're not going
to be afraid of it,
I'd be like, yeah, that's
a pipe dream, right?
No, I'm going to have my
one row per device, right?
I'm not going maintain
a time series,
does literally every single
change in the record,
and I'm going to do it
across multiple systems,
and I'll be able to do it,
write it, pull it, access it
for $130?
Never.
I just would have thought it
never would have happened.
But Google gives
you that chance.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
We are running out
of time, so I just
want to get to one more
thing before we finish.
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS]
I blather on, man.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: It's all right.
You're excited.
I love it.
So you have the data.
It's in Datastore.
Analytics, like
obviously, then, you're,
talking about machine learning.
You're doing all
that kind of stuff.
Are you doing that
directly through Datastore?
I mean, Datastore's
aggregation is not like great.
[LAUGHS]
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: How do you
make that stuff work?
BRIAN GRANATIR: And
that's the other thing.
So I'm glad you brought that up,
because one of the things that
is you get the data in.
You store the data.
But then how do you act upon it?
How do you get that meaning?
How do you say, oh,
well, I want to take data
on the devices that
were telling me parking,
and I want to co-locate it
with the devices from traffic,
right?
How do I do that?
And this is where
BigQuery comes in.
So BigQuery is
probably the granddaddy
of all Google services.
This is probably the
reason most people
listen to these podcasts.
This is probably the reason
most people initially
go look at GCP.
BigQuery is their true
big data analytics system.
And it basically allows you to
go over-- and I've seen demos,
and I've done it myself, where
you can go over terabytes
and terabytes of data.
You can run these
massive queries,
and they'll respond
in five seconds,
just going over these
just huge data sets.
And so that's the key, right?
So we get it Datastore.
But we also replicate
it into BigQuery.
So I have a non-SQL database,
which is really easy for me
to interact with.
It's super easy to do it.
And then I find
aggregates, which
is another event-driven
architecture
system, terminology
rather, that says
I'm co-locating
certain events to make
an aggregate, a
view of something.
So I take those aggregate,
and put them into it
SQL database, start
putting them in BigQuery.
And from there, I can go and do
these huge, wonderful queries
across these massive data sets.
And that's another thing, too.
Go back a year and
tell me, hey, Brian,
you're going to take data.
You're not only going
to put it in just
tons of non-SQL
databases, but you're also
going to replicate it
in an SQL database just
to make it easy to query because
people know how to write a SQL.
They know how to
do all that stuff.
So being able to
say, hey, you're
going to do those two things
because it's cost-efficient, I
just would have said like,
ah, that's the future.
There's no way that's
going to happen.
But it's right here.
We've been doing it, and
it's just been amazing.
And there's another
thing that goes
hand-in-hand with it, right?
You get the data in there.
You query it, but how do
you make it look good?
So Google has Data Studio.
Data Studio allows
you to say, hey, well,
I've got data in BigQuery.
I want to make it
look like a graph.
look like a chart.
I want to make a dashboard.
And it's really easy for
people to go through and do it.
I tell people we had a
project manager on our team,
so nothing against
project managers.
Love me project managers.
But we had a project manager.
She sat down.
And we said, here's Data Studio
tucked into our occupancy
parking data.
Go nuts.
And she sat down and
learned Data Studio, learned
how to query it through
our massive data sets,
and she made a whole report,
and it took her a day, right?
And she's not like
an expert in SQL.
She's not an expert in
any of these things.
She just sat down, connected
the dots for the data stores,
made some graphs, and
was able to present
a report to one of our clients.
And you're like, wow.
So this is often referred to
as the democratization of data.
This is data that's
not only available,
but it's not going to
cost you an arm and a leg
to do a query over it.
And it responds in a way that
anyone could access it, not
just us super geeks, right?
Project managers, data
analysts, marketing PR people,
they can all do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're definitely
running out of time.
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[LAUGHS] But that
was a very, very
interesting conversation.
It's really, really nice to
hear someone as passionate
as you are.
Is there anything else
that you'd like to add?
If not, I actually have
a final question for you.
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah, go
ahead for the final question.
If you ask me to kind
of add stuff to it,
we'd probably be
here another hour.
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so the final question
is, like I said in your
bio, you were a screenwriter
for Hollywood for three years?
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yes.
Yes.
So before I got into
computer science,
I did go down the route of
the liberal arts degree.
And I did get a
degree in English.
And I did end up in
Hollywood and worked there
as a screenwriter
for a few years.
Quite a shift to go
from that and then
get into computer science,
but it was a lot of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Makes sense.
Makes sense.
You're pretty good at telling
stories, I can tell that.
[LAUGHS]
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah,
well, thank you.
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, I
guess our time is over.
So thank you so much
for taking the time
today to tell us your story
and to let us understand
a little bit better how
is Smart Parking gives us
so much data in order
to do smart choices.
BRIAN GRANATIR: Yeah, wonderful.
Thank you so much.
And I'll just give a
shout out to-- while I've
got a little chance-- to just
all the people at Google.
like to say that Google
GCP is not only the system
I use, but you guys are
also my DevOps team.
You guys are on my support team.
You guys are also
my R&D them, right?
I literally have had times where
I come back from the weekend,
and I will find that my
system is running 10% faster.
I didn't do a thing.
Google improved
their Cloud Functions
because Cloud
Functions are amazing.
And of course, I took the
credit for everything, right?
So you guys made me
look really good.
Good work, R&D team.
I want to just say thanks
so much and keep it up.
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, listen,
all of us guys and girls
say you're welcome.
BRIAN GRANATIR: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you again.
BRIAN GRANATIR:
All right, cheers.
MELANIE WARRICK: All
right, thanks, Brian,
for the interview.
That was really great
information and good
to hear that you had such a
positive experience with GCP.
I will switch us over to asking
what the Question of the Week
is.
So, Mark, you want
to run with that?
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
So we were talking previously
about how Postgres now
has high-availability
capabilities where
it didn't before.
But the question is,
how do I actually
go about setting that up?
It's actually really
straightforward.
There are APIs.
But the simplest
way is basically
going into your Cloud
SQL instances page.
You'll see now that there is
a high-availability regional
checkbox.
That will be under
your instance.
It doesn't have to
be an old instance.
You can create a
whole new one as well.
But basically, there's
a checkbox there.
You turn it on.
Enable auto backups
and high availability.
Click Save.
And you are pretty
much good to go.
What's also really
nice about this
is if you want to test what
happens when, say, failover
happens, so your
database goes down,
and it flips over to the backup,
there is a gcloud as well as
an API that you can call.
Basically, you can call
gcloud SQL instances failover.
And that will take down
your primary instance
and then flail you
over to your secondary.
And then you'll be
able to see exactly
what your application's doing.
This is probably
something you want
to do while everyone's
sitting around,
rather than at 3
o'clock in the morning
if something goes wrong so that
you can move ahead and see what
happens.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, and then I'm going to
throw in a second question
of the week.
Mark how are you handling
Francesc leaving?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: It's sad.
I'm very sad.
Francesc and I worked
together for two years.
But I am very excited
to have you on board.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: I'm really
quite excited to see
what ends up happening
with us in the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me too.
And with that, also said, where
are you going to be next week?
Do you have any upcoming
talks or activities?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
I'm not going anywhere
for a little while.
I just got back from Australia,
as everyone just heard.
But I will be at the Montreal
International Games Summit
in December, December 11th.
How about yourself?
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: So next
week, for San Francisco Q
Con I'm going to be speaking on
a panel about machine learning
and AI on the 13th.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds very--
MELANIE WARRICK: Should be.
I'm looking forward to it.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks for getting
me started with our first
podcast is the intros
and outros.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you
for joining me for an episode,
and I look forward
to many to come.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: All right, and
we'll see you all next week.